normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government they
got breaking news this actually uh broke
about an hour ago but we'll get into it
right now from ABC special prosecutor
files nine tax related felony charges
against Hunter Biden special counsel
David David Weiss has filed additional
charges uh Let me refresh to get the
laay information the indictment uh the
in the indictment prosecutors alleg
Hunter Biden engaged in a 4-year scheme
to not pay at least one .4 million in
self assessed federal taxes he owed for
the years 2016 through 19 from in or
from in or about January 2017 to October
15 2020 and to evade the assessment of
taxes for tax year 2018 when he filed
false returns you know about February
2020 is this how they bring down Joe
Biden I about Joe Biden that's how they
got uh taxes is how they got Al Capone
right but I'm want I'm not saying this
right here is how they get Joe Biden I'm
saying this is in relation to yeah one
by one you get these death by Thousand
Cuts of Hunter Biden and then eventually
someone goes hey wait a minute one of
these threads goes to Joe and then Joe
embattled says look I'm going to step
down you know these allegations are
false but that's I you saw the MSNBC
clip where they they're they're
interviewing Joe Biden they're asking
questions like so what do you have to
say about this these conversations
you've had with Hunters Associates when
you were lying and he's like uh it's
it's not true you're lying you're all
lies you're all lying you're
dogf face Pony soldiers all yeah to
answer your question Tim yes I think
this is the track they're going after
the bidens now and then maybe they'll
use the same kind of tax crap to go
after Trump I don't know if they are
they hitting him on tax charges let me
let me let's let's P this clip because
it's kind of crazy to see here's a clip
of uh Joe Biden being questioned on
MSNBC B on Ukraine and also China uh
there is polling by the Associated Press
that shows that almost 70% of Americans
including 40% of Democrats believe that
you acted either illegally or
unethically in regards to your family's
business interest can you explain to the
Americans uh to Americans admit this
impeachment inquiry why you interacted
with so many of your son and brothers
foreign business associates I'm not
going to comment that I did not and it's
just a bunch of Lies didn't interact
with comment isn't it I did not there
lies not I keep hearing Tommy 70% 70%
40% of Democrats think he acted
illegally that's m NBC saying this
that's crazy man I I don't see how Biden
ends up the nominee I you know I don't
either but at the same time because I
know that you know they're all about
that what what's their goal their goal
is power right so I I've always thought
that he's the perfect front man for for
what they're doing because as they
destroy the country systematically they
got the perfect Fall Guy out there the
guy can't put together a sentence he
falls
constantly um they've got a ton of
clearly a ton of dirt on him so he's got
to do what they say and he wanted to
he's wanted to be president forever so
it's like why and when he's when he when
when the as the country collapses on his
watch they can they can blame him you
know so I think he's the perfect Fall
Guy but I wouldn't be surprised to see
the old baiton switch and see a guy like
Nome get thrown in there either so we'll
see what happens man but I wonder what
the prediction markets have Nome at
right now I'm going to check Actually I
don't even know which one's wor I don't
even know what what would be worse for
the country honestly I think it's Mr
surrender Afghanistan is probably worse
he this guy surrendered the most
powerful military on Earth to the
Taliban and and $80 billion worth of
equipment he surrendered how many people
died over there in that surrender 19
people died in the bomb that went off
and and women throwing their babies
trying to throw their babies over barb
wire to get them inside a military base
the babies are getting caught in the
wire like that's because of him he
called he made that call to get rid of
bam Air Force Base air superiority and
just left everybody in the Lurch with
the rushed surrender the most terrible
military executive I've ever seen in
power in the United States I I agree but
I don't you know a lot of people think
Biden's in charge or someone's pulling
the leash and I'm kind of like no I
think they're letting him flounder
they're sitting back watching it just
letting it roll out because like you
said when it all comes crashing down
they want to burn it down they want to
replace it with something else they just
blame Biden and then he's gone he's he's
there he's their he's their Psy perfect
Fall Guy but but you're right that is I
mean it is scary it's it's one of
Afghanistan was definitely one of the uh
you know big massive failures I I was in
the SEAL Teams for a little bit and uh
and one of the things that scared me or
concerned me when I was looking at the
list of gear Left Behind was all the
night vision goggles because you know as
as when you're operating overseas a lot
of times we we would almost exclusively
operate at night because we own the
night right but now that these guys have
all that night vision equipment that's
going to make it really difficult for
any of our troops or any of our allies
that are fighting at night and you know
that definitely takes our superiority
and our advantage down I don't know how
like how many they actually left but you
know that they're not staying in
Afghanistan either it's it's getting
into uh combat zones all over the world
and like I mean anybody that's got you
know played around with night vision it
is a
completely different thing to be able to
see at night when when the people that
you're going after can't see no look I
think most City people I I I I I there's
a lot of people listening right now who
are going to be like n Tim's most City
people don't know what nighttime is like
yeah so in that famous story about La
power goes out the police get a bunch of
phone calls about something strange in
the sky it was the first time they had
seen the Milky Way yeah so when the
lights are all out and it's dark so when
we have a a new moon out here where
we're at we have we have lights set up
on the side of the driveway we have uh
motion lights not just for us to be able
to see but for security reasons too but
uh I you you you walk down the driveway
during a new moon it is Pitch Black yeah
and and I'm like you are blind 100% you
put on the night fishing goggles we got
and it is daylight yeah we also have
daylight flashlights which are cool too
though no it's it's true man it's one of
the most surreal
experiences that I've ever had walking
through one of the you know very big
cities some of the most violent cities
in the world um but nobody's on the
streets but you and a you know a couple
of your buddies patrolling and it's
that's why it's because we have we have
that technology and they don't and now
you see it left behind like that and
it's just like f the first time you put
them on and you could see satellites
it's crazy yeah it's like it's like the
movie Step Brothers right yeah when you
were you were you in when they had were
they had Panos yeah did aan or you mean
the are you talking about Finos no no no
the four no I I never had had the uh I
never had those I always had the binos
what are the Pinos binos are just two
two or four the Panos there's four tubes
yeah so you can actually see a wider
range yeah so when when uh I first first
time I ever used them was actually like
two years ago or whatever I bought a
pair and you look at the sky and it's
like there's a satellite it's insane
they're shooting stars like they're up
there happening right now and you just
oh yeah oh oh yeah you you're seeing
them go shooting across when you're
wearing those things it's it's nuts and
then you're like walking around like I
can see everything
czy how much are those cost how do we
get those those those are $42,000 oh wow
how many of those were left were
surrendered do you know offand roughly
how many he could he could Google it
right now I know it wasn't it wasn't 15
of them it was thousand thousands and
thousand they probably they probably
actually left binos they probably didn't
leave Panos Panos were are the uh the
really high expensive ones only that
that he was on seal that's why I asked
because the SEAL Teams in Delta the guys
that get Panos everyone else gets Pinos
plans guns and night vision I mean yeah
I I don't see how Afghanistan was an
accident how do you you don't
accidentally abandon your Air Force Base
in the middle of the night without
telling your partners yeah yeah that
that that that one's tough to explain so
what do you do in the military you
served it with the seals like if your
commander or orders a surrender like
abruptly that causes Mass death and and
loss of equipment and life like what
happens to that
Commander I guess it depends on who the
leadership at the top is right the
military
you know I think for a long time has
been I think for a long time it been
spared from a lot of the insanity of
this culture but even over the last
couple years you've seen you know it it
it it you know infect the military as
well like I just we we had a uh we had
an Air Force Admiral in homeland
security I think this last week and he
was talking about um some of their
issues and one of their big issues was
Recruitment and I asked him do you think
it has anything to do with the you know
Dei training do you think it has
anything to do with you know drag shows
on base you know that that type of stuff
that never never really was in the
military um and he's like no he and and
he chocked it up to covid and I asked
him well do you think it has anything to
do with forcing uh our service members
to take an experimental
vaccine um and you know basically he was
he was like well you know I I don't know
about that and I was like do you now the
armed forces are actually offering these
guys that didn't take the vaccine to
come back in yeah right and they said oh
and we'll we'll clear your record right
after they forced them out many of them
had families had to find a new job you
know whatever and and they didn't get on
I don't believe they got honorable
discharges right I think it was
administrative wasn't it I I I don't
remember you you you might be right Tim
um but you know I asked him do you think
that had anything to do with it and he's
basically said you know I'm not you know
I'm not not uh I'm not able to comment
on that who was that some it was some
air force or I'm sorry not Air Force it
was the Coast Guard Admiral General
discharge under honorable conditions
okay so uh that that's what I guess is
being reported just so that Admiral
knows if you own up to the truth they'll
be more likely to reinlist yeah it was
because they were forced to take a
vaccine that they didn't trust and they
quit because of it or they were
discharged because of it and now they're
being asked to come back like what have
some humility guy Admiral I well that's
the problem like the military is one of
the most dangerous jobs you can have and
if you if you don't have any faith that
leadership's not going to sell you out
if if you believe that your leadership
will stab you in the back you know so
they can continue to get promoted how
many people do you think are going to
join and that's that's the thing it's
like a lot a lot of these young kids I
mean and I think there's multiple issues
there but a lot of these young kids
don't trust this the leadership that
they just saw you know be in charge of
the debacle in Afghanistan and that you
know forced a bunch of our troops to get
an experimental vaccine and now that
they can't recruit kids to come back in
you know they're offering hey to bring
them back I mean it's just it's a
complete leadership disaster what do you
think would be a good incentive to get
people
back well I think I think an apology to
start with would be really nice and
these these guys taking ownership and be
like hey we screwed up okay we screwed
up secondly like my little brother you
know went he was a cobra pilot in the
Marine Corp he I think he was on his
last year in the Marine Corps and was
basically told you're getting the V
you're getting the vaccine or you're out
and so my little brother went to the
Naval Academy like flew helicopters you
know High performing guy actual actual
officer not worn up yeah he was he was
an O and uh he lost his retirement cuz
he wouldn't put that in his body and so
take you you got to take care of those
you got to take care of those guys and
then you got to you got to take care of
the the folks that are injured now
because of the vaccine as well and just
make them feel like hey we got your back
because if you don't got my back when it
comes to you know this stuff right here
you I don't I don't think you're going
to have my back when we're going to war
against the CCP or we're going to war
against Iran and and you know I'm I'm
I'm out there by myself and I need some
air support and to the to the point that
you were making earlier about the about
cultural Marxism and stuff the the goal
of that kind of stuff is to shake
people's uh faith and and in the in the
our our system in the United States and
so if you've got you know graduating
class after graduating class after
graduating class being churned out of
high schools and colleges that have been
taught that America's not really all
that good America's not worth fighting
for America's a bad force a force for
evil in the world America's the the the
villain on the global scale normally uh
and generally that's the the the role
that the US has had since the end of
World War II if that's what you've been
taught why would you join the military
to serve the the government right like
there's no reason to I want to do like a
mini segment real quick have you guys
heard about what's going on with
Venezuela and Guyana yeah no what's
happening Venezuela's declaring
ownership of the western portion of the
nation of Guyana and amassing its
military and now Guyana is requesting us
Aid to prevent The Invasion it's over
half of the country that they're making
a claim to it's not just a a small part
socialists want stuff for free and and
so part of the reason why they're doing
this is because um uh EX mobile was just
doing uh Explorations out off the Ghana
coast and so they want to go after after
Ghana's basically they guy guyana's uh
um Ghana and the other Ghana yeah no my
bad Guyana and Ghana and so they're
going out so it's after the capitalists
have done the exploring to find the oil
reserves that you would only be able to
find with tools provided or invented for
capitalist uh exploration and now the
Socialists like y that's mine but you
know me that I just want to say like
you've got Middle Eastern conflict
you've got Eastern European conflict you
now have an escalating together was it
you're tying it together yeah oh yeah
now you got South American conflict and
we're southeast Asia is right on the
horizon too on fire this would be a
World War also with sou with the stuff
going on in South America there is the
Monroe Doctrine that we have to worry
about if there's anyone that decides
that they're going to uh support
Venezuela that would be from the you
know from Asia or from from you know
whether it be uh
Russia or China or whatever if they or
Iran if they decide they want to support
Venezuela then the US has the mon
Doctrine which is saying that no one
from from any other part from the from
the Eastern hemisphere has any business
being in the Western Hemisphere this is
the total the domain totally the domain
of the United States and we will not
accept countries from Europe or from uh
Asia or from the Middle East or from
Africa meddling in North or South
America we just totally reject out of
hand and so now the US is in a situation
where if anyone does decide to go ahead
and support Venezuela then the us is
going to talk about the Monro Doctrine
and say you can't be here I don't think
it even matters if Russia Iran or China
gets involved with Venezuela the fact is
if we have war in South America war in
Southeast Asia war in Eastern Europe War
in the Middle East you've got World War
that's that's kind of how World War II
like melini started that and with his
North African Conquest he gave Hitler
the green light basically he was like
Hey look you can conquer your neighbors
and no one's stopping me and then Hitler
was like oo wow I like that and and
Japan it's not like these these are
neighboring countries y Japan war was
you do it which justifies that guy doing
it which justifies that guy doing it and
then you've got like a smash and grab
situation where everyone's like well
before this is over I'm going to see if
I can get a piece maybe not justify but
basically creates the opportunity yeah
justify in their own minds I should say
I mean is there really ever a
justification for offensive War I don't
know yeah but but the scarier thing I
suppose is as Phils bring with Monroe
Doctrine is Guyana is asking the us to
prevent The Invasion so what do you guys
think we should we going to get involved
in war in Venezuela I don't think so but
I'd rather have our aircraft carriers
there than in the in I agree Red Sea or
something I agree because we're talking
about having our forces in the Gulf all
I can say is I'm missing some Mean
Tweets right about now yeah are you
involved with this kind of the military
stuff in the I mean you know it's like
uh involved in in uh the function of
funding that that's the power the purse
is probably the biggest tool that
Congress has and so funding the military
and then also funding you know I would
say our our projects o overseas and
Foreign Affairs that that's a lot of
congresses and obviously Congress can
declare war as well but that that
doesn't happen too often thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday Friday at 8:00 p.m. and
become a member over at timcast.net